returning to the war in Ukraine now
prime minister Justin Trudeau's surprise
visit to Kiev today an announcement of
new support comes at a crucial time in
the conflict
after rapid Russian gains at the onset
of the war Ukrainian forces made steady
progress regaining territory but since
the start of this year that progress has
slowed and Russian forces are entrenched
along much of eastern Ukraine and Crimea
joining us now is Suzanne Loftus
research fellow at the Quincy
institute's Eurasia program Suzanne
thanks for being with us we're now over
15 months into this conflict and of
course some thought that Russia might
claim a quick Victory but Ukraine has
had supportive countries like Canada and
the U.S how important has that been and
how much is Ukraine relying on that
assistance to continue
Ukraine is
to
defending itself against Russian
aggression it has been the most
important source of support from NATO
countries and it has enabled and allowed
Ukraine to properly defend itself
without that support the Russians would
have been able to advance much further
than they already have and this includes
not just Military Support but also
humanitarian support but at the same
time while the support is very important
we need to strategize about how long
it's going to last and how long we're
going to be financing what's going on in
Ukraine right now we need to kind of
come up with an end game
and that's I think what a lot of people
are wondering about speaking of support
though there was a major event in the
conflict this week the destruction of a
dam on the nepro river do we know who
destroyed it and why
we still don't know who the perpetrator
was it would be improbable that it would
be the Russians actually because this
hurts them a lot as well it floods all
of their the Russian controlled parts of
there's agriculture that's flooding but
also it's preventing the supply of water
to Crimea and this is a very important
uh you know this is very important in
general for the Russians so it would
seem a little odd that they would do
that to themselves so at this point we
don't know who did it it's possible that
it could have been unintentional and
that it just got destroyed over time due
to limited strikes that caused them
weaknesses
how is the destruction of the dam
impacted Ukraine's counter-offensive
yeah so right now because of all the
flooding ukrainians are not conducting
the any large-scale activities in that
region but that would just be temporary
they could do so later when the Waters
of sides at this moment the main
counter-offensive movement and activity
has been seen mostly in Donetsk we've
also seen summons operations
but this is also not quite the major
units are not quite sent yet this is
more of a preliminary phase to kind of
test Russian vulnerabilities and uh so
we're yet to see a major activity
you know you touched on this a bit
earlier but both sides appear entrenched
are there any options for an exit from
this conflict
well at this moment both sides are
extremely far away from one another in
the sense that there doesn't seem to be
any type of Middle Ground possible
between the two and at the same time
there's also what appears to be somewhat
of a stalemated situation on the ground
where both sides are making very small
gains or small losses Suzanne Loftus
from the Quincy institute's Eurasia
program thanks so much for being with us
thank you for having me